this week was a big story the Supreme
Court ruled that a Colorado Baker did
not did not have to sell a cake to a
same-sex couple because their marriage
violated his religious beliefs okay and
that was the court's ruling shortly
after the court's decision this ad
appeared all over the media showed the
world that you're okay with same-sex
marriage by boycotting all forms of
wedding cake serve a pie instead a
message from the United States pie
Council okay I don't have to take a
second here and just be honest with you
there is no such thing as the United
States pie Council fake Counsel ads are
the laziest form of late-night comedy
all it takes is a bunch of photos some
music and a voiceover
don't let lazy Hollywood writers get
away with it
a message from the no faith councils
Council see what they did the no fake
councils Council was a joke about the
joke form itself also known as a medic
joke meta jokes were big in the 1990 but
now they're just a cheap way to put
ironic distance on a comedy bit you
don't have faith in a message from the
United States by council that's right
the united states pine council that's
known as a call back when you're too
lazy to come up with a new joke bring
back a joke you already did by the way
this whole thing is called
deconstructing a sketch that is the
worst kind of comedy imaginable
while those hotshot Hollywood writers
are busy masturbating each other with
their high concept shenanigans they've
dug a deep comedy hole for Conan and
they have no idea how to get him out
a message from the United States PI
Council
good evening I'm Conan O'Brien when my
writers put me in a deep conceptual
comedy hole only one thing can get the
studio audience back on my side again
that's right
YouTube clips of kids hitting their dads
in the groin
[Music]
see it works every time a message from
the United States by county no wait a
minute that was not a message from the
message from the United States wagons Oh
we'll be right back with kate mara
[Applause]
you
[Applause]
you